my inspiration has undoubtedly been my
mother she encouraged me to think
independently to be curious and to speak
up for myself I started computer science
I was terrified of the first classes I
had to take but I eventually became
really close with my algorithms
professors and she inspired me to try
and spory now two projects on my own and
learning about your pills and your
science so when I go speak at
conferences like the Google cloud summit
I really want to make sure everyone
they're empowered and safe to ask
questions take charge of their own
careers and bring their new perspectives
to the table I work in security and so
asking questions is really really
critical people who could work in
security come from a variety of
backgrounds whether they come from
literature from computer science from
from a marginalized group whatever it
happens to be and they say you know how
do we actually make this work better for
the user if you're not doing that you're
potentially missing out on a key part of
the job one manager in particular has
always said to me look don't mind if
you've got a problem but I'd appreciate
you actually haven't thought that
problem through and look and question it
even if it's an area that's not my area
of expertise I do try and actually look
around it at that problem look around it
to see how I can deal with it I became a
working mom I work fearlessly day and
night for when I work for a gentleman
named Paul there came an external career
opportunity he encouraged me to step out
of my comfort zone and go for the bigger
career when I first joined Google one of
the very first things I heard is a great
quote from Larry Page which is about
having a healthy disregard for the
impossible
and with a healthy disregard for the
impossible people can do anything and I
think that's incredibly powerful
[Music]